ratagon of the golden order what a
complete mystery of a character almost
as much as queen merica herself although
we all know at this point that radagon
is queen america it's still a complete
mystery as to how this is even possible
how can one being also be another while
at the same time have different
conscious minds america is the one who
shattered the elden ring while her other
half ratagon tried to mend it back
together can they take control of each
other can they split apart how can they
possibly have children together they
clearly can't stop one another before
their action is complete otherwise
ratagon would have stopped merica from
shattering the elden ring in the first
place it seems like they also can't read
each other's minds for the exact same
reason it's impossible to say but what
we do know is that ratagon is america
the question i want to discuss today
with all of you watching is who is
ratagon where did he come from why was
he chosen to be the second elden lord is
he even real or is he just a
manifestation of some kind to stop
merica from fulfilling her clear
intentions to oppose the golden order
all of these questions are difficult to
understand probably impossible to answer
at this point but are regardless still
fun to discuss with all that said please
understand that this video is a theory
discussion and nothing that i say in
this video is set in stone factual i
love coming up with interesting theories
and discussing it with all of you i find
it fun if you don't you are in the wrong
place my friend if you do welcome make
sure to like subscribe all that good
stuff my dog joy gets tummy rubs if you
do and if you're good with all that
let's get to it so where can we find
most of the in-game information on
ratagon from what i've found muriel
gives us an insane amount of information
on radagon and related topics lord
radigan was a great champion
possessed of flowing red locks
he came to these lands at the head of a
great golden host
when he met lady ranala in battle
he soon repented his territorial
aggressions there
and became husband to the karyan queen
so the timeline here is important in
understanding this relationship between
ratagon and ranala was ratagon already
also america when he came to the lands
between and battled against granala his
arrival on a great golden host suggests
that he was already a part of the golden
order was he at this point just split
from his body with america in order to
battle against opposing factions of the
golden order one theory suggests that
america knowingly took control of
ratagon started a consort ship with
ranala just to
in the end leave her to break her heart
ranala when we meet her in game is
obviously not in her normal frame of
mind if america intended for this to
happen where ronaldo loses her sanity
after her heart is broken it clearly
worked in regards to ranala no longer
being a threat against the golden order
even her own followers just locked her
away in the library of raya lucaria and
her daughter ronnie had to create a trap
spell just to protect her this spell
shows us how powerful ronaldo can be in
her right frame of mind her full
potential known as the queen of the full
moon but after we defeat this version of
her we come back to her real self fully
infatuated with the glowing egg she
constantly holds onto this egg is
actually a great rune the great rune of
the unborn that was given to her by
ratagon also told to us by muriel in the
end lady ranala was left alone
cradling the amber egg lord radicand
bequeathed her
now she devotes herself to it through
forbidden right
the grim art of reincarnation
i find this to be a bit confusing based
on the timeline how did radagon get his
hands on a great rune before he became
the elden lord this great rune is not a
rune that you can take to any divine
tower and obtain a certain power up from
it is however one of the great runes you
can use to get into the capital city and
mend the elden ring its description
reads amber egg clutch by ranala queen
of the full moon great rune of unborn
demigods perfects those who have been
born anew children born anew by ranala
are all frail and short-lived imperfect
beings each and all i'd love to go into
more detail regarding ranala because i
think her story is much deeper than i've
seen discussed at this point but let's
stick to ratagon for this video the
description here suggests that this
great rune is of the unborn demigods if
we listen to some dialogue from ranala
we can learn a bit more about this egg
is it thy wish to be born anew
to become a sweeting
reborn of my beloved egg
it seemeth
a sweeting rather fair
and if thou art born anew once more
i would be fairer still
ye will be countless born
forever so while understanding what she
means by this is obviously very
difficult i think it's an important hint
in terms of ratagon's major theme this
egg was gifted to ranala by ratagon and
she is clearly obsessed with him and the
rebirthing properties this egg has when
we use this respeccing option in-game we
have the option to completely change how
we look we can reallocate points into
the attributes we want to change our
build you can even change your own name
it's very clear when we talk more about
ratagon with muriel that ratagon wanted
to change himself as well
when godfrey first elden lord was
hounded from the lands between
radigan left rinala to return to the
earth tree capital
becoming queen america's second husband
and king consort
taking the title of second elden lord
the mystery endures to this day
as to why lord radigan would cast lady
ranala aside
and moreover
why a mere champion would be chosen for
the seat of eldon lord muriel says that
radagon returned to the earth tree
capital to become the second elden lord
so this wording suggests that radagon
was separated from america during this
consort ship with ranala and was a
champion or warrior for the golden order
before becoming its new elden lord
however ratagan regretted his
territorial aggressions while fighting
for the golden order and he wanted to
change the church of vows where we talk
to muriel signifies the peace between
the golden order and the qarian royals
radican once cleansed himself with
celestial dew
repented his territorial aggressions
and swore his love to rinala the order
of the urgery and the fate of the moon
were conjoined
and all the wounds of war forgiven
this miracle blesses the church to this
day
and so you need only follow ratigan's
example
to restore
any bond however strained or severed to
its rightful state of harmony
radagon made a major effort to change
his ways in order to achieve harmony and
peace in the lands between as muriel
says it's a complete mystery as to why
radagon left his consort ship with
ranala and it's also a mystery as to why
queen america would even choose ratagon
to become the new elden lord what makes
the most sense is that radagon was the
most powerful warrior for the golden
order after godfrey was banished
strength seems to be the only criteria
to becoming the elden lord brave
tarnished
thy strength
befits a crown
it still seems very odd for radagon to
completely abandon what he had with
ronald he swore his love for her and
it's clear that ronaldo loved him just
as much in return either becoming the
new elden lord was enticing enough for
radagon to just leave her or he was
forced to return to the archery we find
out from the golden order principa in
the lap of this person sitting in a
hanging chair that ratagon is merica you
can learn two incantations from this
principal the law of regression and
ratagon's rings of light the law of
regression description says that the
fundamentalists describe the golden
order through the powers of regression
and causality regression is the pull of
meaning that all things yearn eternally
to converge which essentially means a
return to a former state the law of
causality is the relationship between
cause and effect the principle that
everything has a cause it's the pull
between meanings that which links all
things in a chain of relation these are
the golden orders fundamental principles
using the law of regression incantation
in front of this statue in the capital
city is a vivid representation of this
the statue depicts ratagon and changes
into america after we use the law of
regression this could be suggesting that
ratagon returned to his original form
which is america through the fundamental
principles of the golden order itself
i've made a lot of theories regarding
queen america but i believe it's pretty
clear that america wanted to change the
golden order and take away its influence
in one way or another america's own
words
i declare mine intent
to search the depths of the golden order
through understanding of the proper way
our faith
our grace is increased
those blissful early days of blind
belief are long past
both ratagon and america have their own
sore seals and scar seals both of which
say the same thing they are eyes
ingrained with an elden rune each scar
seal represents the lifelong duty of
those chosen by the gods each sore seal
reads as the solemn duty weighs upon the
one beholden not unlike a gnawing curse
from which there is no deliverance both
essentially saying the same thing that
there is a lifelong duty for those
chosen by the gods and it is a duty that
you can never be set free from if we
look closely at ratagon during the final
boss fight we can see that he's
literally withering away his body has
turned into this type of stone that's
breaking apart the same goes for queen
america it seems to me that the elden
ring can be removed from the vessel that
holds it together these sore seals and
scar seals could be the actual eyes of
america and ratagon since they seem to
be missing their eyes in many parts of
their body when we find them inside the
erd tree america gave her children their
own great runes before shattering the
elden ring likely in an effort to weaken
the golden order before delivering the
final blows using merica's hammer the
description of this item reads as the
tool with which queen america shattered
the elden ring and radagon attempted to
repair it the hammer partially broke
upon shattering the ring becoming
splintered with rune fragments these
splintered fragments remind me of the
backdrop of ratagon's statue this is
likely meant to represent ratagon's
mission to fix what was broken ratagan's
icon reads as a legendary talisman
depicting the elden lord ratagan as the
husband of ranala of karya the
red-haired ratagon studied sorcery and
as the husband of queen america he
studied incantations thus did the hero
aspire to be complete so what i'm
getting from all of this information on
radagon is that he was genuinely trying
to change his ways and become whole on
his own instead of coming back to queen
america to do so which would be the law
of regression in the golden order the
eternal urge to return back to their
previous state which is enhanced by
their seals that signify their lifelong
duty to serve the greater will based on
this law it didn't matter how hard
radagon tried to change his ways it
didn't matter how many times he tried to
cleanse himself of his sins he is bound
by the laws of the golden order to
return to queen america however his
attempts to do so created the church of
vows and there was at least some amount
of time that peace did exist and he was
forgiven for his previous territorial
aggressions the only reason he left
ranala was because he had to by law and
if he didn't his secret would likely be
revealed to the lands between you know
it's said that lord radican harbored a
secret
a famed sculptor of the earth tree
capital was once summoned to render lord
ratigan's likeness in giant stature
when he glimpsed the skeleton in
ralligan's closet
and as such it's said the great statue
harbors his secret too the only famed
sculptor i can think of is the sculptor
of these mini statues in the shaded
castle if this sculptor knew of
ratagon's secret and made it possible
for the secret to be revealed by using
the law of regression then where is this
sculptor it's hard to say it seems like
the shaded castle has been abandoned and
completely overrun i made a video about
this area a few months back if you're
interested but in regards to who the
sculptor is this is pure speculation but
i'd have to think it would be this body
that we can find in the capital again
this is where we can find the golden
order principal which is how we can
reveal the hidden secret of the statue
the hanging chair the body lays in could
be to adjust the height when working on
a sculpture it's also possible that this
sculptor was killed by the black knife
assassin that we can find outside the
queen's bedchamber this is likely all in
an attempt to hide their secret because
it looks bad for the golden orders of
vessel to be having children with
herself no one bats an eye when ratagon
and america have children but if it's
known that they're actually the same
person it could damage the reputation of
the order it seems like even after his
return to the urgery to serve as the
elden lord ratagon continued his
attempts to mend broken relationships
throughout the family in the lands
between mostly in regards to mycola
where they gifted each other
incantations mikala gifted ratagon the
triple rings of light incantation and
radagon gifted michela ratagan's rings
of light which reads as a gift of
gratitude to the young mykola from his
father ratagon and yet the young mykola
abandoned fundamentalism where it could
do nothing to treat melania's accursed
rod this was the beginning of unalloyed
gold this is what i mean when i suggest
that radagon is attempting to mend his
relationships with his children they
were both born of afflictions nicola
born of eternal youth and melania
harboring the scarlet rot since birth
were they born with these afflictions
because ratagon and america are the same
person some kind of incest birth defect
of some kind it's really hard to
pinpoint this obviously these
incantations gifted from ratagon
temicola could have been an attempt at
helping mikola find a cure for melania's
scarlet rot and when mikala found that
fundamentalism couldn't help her he
abandoned it all together and just moved
on mikala also created the hail tree to
help the albanorics in the misbegotten
find refuge from those who wish to
destroy them this is the only reason i
can think of as to why we find a
misbegotten crusader in the foreign cave
of the consecrated snow fields wielding
the golden order greatsword the
description of the sword reads
greatsword made of light modeled after
the elden ring itself forged by king
consort ratagon to proudly symbolize the
tenets of the golden order telltale
signs betray that this was once the
great sword bequeathed to him by his
first wife ranala this sword could have
been given to this misbegotten by
ratagon or mykola because of mykola's
intent to save the misbegotten people it
was a chance for radagon to help his son
in his attempts to do so while also
spreading the influence of the golden
order to other factions to portray peace
and forgiveness just like he did with
ranala in the carrion royals or this
misbegotten just found the sword we
really can't say this is all quite a
stretch i'm sure so make sure to tell me
what you think down in the comments
there's a lot here and it's easy to
think of these situations through
completely different perspectives all of
which i'm sure is entirely plausible in
the end i believe ratagon didn't have a
choice to fight against us when we
entered the earth tree it's hard to say
how much damage the shattering of the
elden ring did to both ratagon and
america's mind and body to me they look
completely broken and are barely held
together when ratagon fights us it looks
like he's being used like a puppet by
the greater will and once we defeat him
a manifestation of the greater will the
elden beast literally uses radagon yet
again to become the be sword known as
the sacred relic sword which reads as a
sword wrought with the remains of a god
who should have lived a life eternal
thoughts on what the weapon pretends are
many and varied some consider it the
mark of a great sin or a sign of great
devastation some think of it as the end
of an age while others the beginning
just like with most of the story with
elden ring it can mean many different
things to many different people to me
ratagon wanted to show america and
himself that it was possible to change
without the need for the destruction of
the golden order that the laws can be
changed and that forgiveness for past
sins can be earned when there's an
attempt by both sides to do so i believe
he genuinely loved ranala and he found
that it was impossible for him not to
return to the golden order ratagon in
ranala's relationship was built entirely
on the foundation of the church of vows
where he swore his love for her he
repented his past and cleansed himself
to seek forgiveness in the end it didn't
seem to work ratagon returned to the
urgery and this completely destroyed
ranala's heart my next planned video is
actually on ranala and so far it's
turned out to be
much more heartbreaking than i
originally thought ratagan's return also
confirmed with merica that the elden
ring needed to be destroyed as it seemed
like it was truly impossible to change
however muriel's faith in ratagon's will
to change has never wavered i'll leave
you all today with his wise words that i
think truly explain what ratagon was
trying to achieve
the shattering has caused us
all of us to lose sight of something
very dear
my faith does not waver
the miracle rooted in these grounds
will once again mend the world
and this time
its bounty will not be squandered
if you would be elden lord
tarnished
i hope that you too will share my faith
[Music]
you